we're back in your hometown of Nashville
how many requests are you getting who's
calling you just saying dog can you give
me some tickets can you take it Rock The
Rock right because they smell what the
Rockets
dude listen I could not believe he he's
been my friend forever but he not only
posted it he posted the album cover yeah
the second biggest Instagram on Earth
yeah and he's you know little old me Man
or big old me whatever he said you had a
friendship for quite some time but he
also listened to your music during some
of the darkest days in his life so how
did y'all originally strike up a
friendship I'm not making this up The
Rock was listening to Jelly Roll music
when Spotify numbers said only 30 000
people were listening to jelly he's
really been with me from the beginning
um I don't I don't I don't share what
that story is but he has a story that
the music was there for him at a moment
when he needed it and
um and that was awesome to hear from him
this is six five six seven years ago
eight years ago even wow and we've kept
in touch he was the first person to
congratulate me on my Grand old Opry day
you first person to congratulate when I
played the rhyming the first DM I got
when I announced Bridgestone I mean
these Pinnacles in my career he's always
the first person in my messages I'm
thinking we need a little collaboration
right well hey I told him I'm gonna lose
some weight and get my acting chops
together baby I want him to sing a song
with me at the Grand Ole Opry and I want
to do a movie with him even if I'm an
extra like if I'm just in the background
you know just cooling man we're
manifesting everything manifest
baby I love you
[Music]
you have so much to celebrate this week
especially that new country debut album
that you've got out yeah Whitsett Chapel
congratulations and how does it feel to
finally have that debut country album
out for the world to hear you know it's
it's I say the word unreal all the time
because I look at my name on the
Billboard Chart and I'm like you dream
of that when you're a kid like the
amount of times that I've scratched out
people's name on a Billboard Chart and
put mine on there and with a white out
pen and when I was in you know middle
school or something so you see these
moments and you're like this can't
really be me having this moment that you
always see people have and now I'm how
can we talk about your new single killer
man oh dude which is all about your wife
it is how you met her in Vegas yes oh
she's the best man
[Applause]
[Music]
I have attempted to write a thousand
love songs and I thought all of them
were a little corny I love love songs
but I'm not corny guy and some love
songs get a little cheesy yeah so I was
like how do I write a song and keep my
my boy
just completely open myself to how much
how in love I am because I mean she
changed my life I am over the moon with
that woman she's done ever I could I
don't see any other woman on Earth but
her and I wanted to write a song that
reflected that and that was vulnerable
yeah and I mean you guys are quite the
duo to say the least I've seen you in
action on those carpets so but he's
always bringing it but you said with
this new album that you wanted it to be
both hopeful and therapeutic how do you
feel like the album represents both of
those to you jelly roll well I think one
I'm constantly writing songs to show
people that it's okay to be a work in
progress It's okay to still meet
yourself in the middle but I also wanted
to make sure this time that I added the
hopefulness to it and the tempo I had
some Tempo changes I wanted to be more
uplifting more major Keys I've been so
long just these sad daunting songs that
I wanted to give people a reason to move
around yeah I mean this guy's going from
mixtapes to I every time I jump in my
truck he is always playing
you talk about that transition and save
me was all about
show putting your struggles out there
and people identify with that what does
that mean to you that so many people
identified with your struggles and how
you kind of grown thank you there's
thank you for the question there's no
amount of celebrity or money that will
ever mean more than the lady I just seen
in the parking lot that's from Antioch
Tennessee and asked could she take a
picture and just told me her brief piece
of her story and what she's overcame in
life and how I Inspire that yeah nothing
no you dude you could throw billions of
dollars at me it'll never have the
effect that I get that feeling when fans
tell me the music helped them because
long before I wrote a song music helped
me right you've even said music has
saved you you would not be here or you
would be in jail without music and here
you are I mean you got to think
sometimes I said it last night on stage
the first time I ever said it out loud
I think at some point in life everything
in life has let me down but music was
always my consistent like when I had
nothing else I had a Boombox when I was
incarcerated I had a set of headphones
and a little radio yeah like the darkest
moments of my life at my father's
funeral it was music that helped me cope
so it's these kind of things these
darkest moments of My Life music was
always there to give me a hug yeah so I
just want to do that for people when
someone else who has not let you down
Miss Bailey Ann your daughter has been
great inspiration to you so how did she
Inspire this album in your new music
well to say she hasn't let me down a
little bit okay
she's a teenager too right now and she
let me down I'm afraid she's gonna take
a mailbox out I don't know why kids do
it when they first learn how to drive
but they hug hard right dude I'm like
kid we're going to clear a mailbox for
sure but uh she changed my life man I I
wanted to be a father that need to be
the example of the men in her life the
rest of her life that I needed to be
present and focused and attentive and
knowing I had her it was weird I never
planned on doing anything with my life
but being a criminal until that okay so
now explain your love for golf when did
you start golfing and are you a golfer
I'm a golfer Dave listen man my short
game is strong as you would expect from
any fat fella but my long games
sometimes sometimes I can't get around
like a YouTube my younger clothes but
now I'm telling you man 40 yards in I'm
shooting darts really oh yeah you DJ
Khaled everybody's picking up golf again
oh dude it's great Daniel Cormier the
UFC light heavyweight heavyweight
champions got in the golf recently it's
so fun to watch everybody's golfing it's
cool you actually wanted to live on a
golf course you were purchasing a home
in a subdivision here in Tennessee and
you were unable to do so because of your
criminal past so where are you in the
midst of that now well I'm still
obviously can't live there I'd love to
meet with the governor it's not even
about my felony I just love to discuss
juvenile reform and I know he's open to
the conversation his office has reached
out and said they'd love to set up a
meeting which is awesome I just want to
discuss with them that I understand the
serious felonies and I understand that
felons should be held accountable and
that felons should have to jump through
little Cheerios of fire in the earth I
believe that I believe that we did that
to ourselves but I believe that if we
have jumped through those little hula
hoops of Fire
that we should be able to come out the
other side reconciled and we see a lot
of that in the documentary so what was
it like opening up being vulnerable I've
took every pill you could you could by
the time I was 15 16 done cocaine
nothing about anything I was doing at
any moment during my childhood felt like
I was out of place even watching it back
I was like man I really was wrong like I
let these people really film the real
and it was uneasy and uncomfortable in a
good way because I believe that the only
thing that creates change is when
something is just a little uncomfortable
there's a famous phrase in recovery that
says uh you'll only have the the power
to change when the pain to remain the
same is greater than the pain it takes
to actually change so it was cool to
watch that and I think that the honesty
is what's making the documentary connect
because I think they're seeing real up
close real raw stuff
[Music]